one of the things that I have found over
the years of doing sketches is that when
when there's an insult written in for me
I you know and they make fun they say
like oh you know you're you look like a
red-haired woman who's too tall or
something you actually you actually get
a little hurt sometimes because the
insults the writers come up with are
really good and it's all supposed to be
in good fun I guess but I'm just curious
like do you guys have that experience
where the where there's a line where
they write an insult for you
you know like Sam have never been an
insult where they've written for your
character but you almost take it to
heart well yeah because I mean yeah one
episode
Amy calls me a Paddington Bear looking
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hit the gym muscle muscle bear Tony we
heard we heard we heard [ __ ] mine was
there another one that that thing is
when it's not even scripted yeah
everyone read read just threw out he's
like hey cow eyes scrip people did you
have one that bothered you I mean like
it was just two weeks ago a beefy blonde
got put in there what yeah but I was I
was still breastfeeding when we were
when we were shooting so I think that
that's where that came from
yeah okay guys it's all right yeah thank
you and and I'm just mat wuts has there
been an insult that really hit home for
you couple come to mind one was you gay
Irish fireman
[Laughter]
[Applause]
they're seen in last week's episode
where we're Matt or Mike was wearing a
too much sunscreen and I referred to him
it's the world's least Geisha stories on
our show by the way
Ryan could not be with us and he is I
love that character he could not be with
us tonight I love his character he is
one of the worst people ever that's all
I can say he's just one of the worst
most horrible people ever and people are
constantly he's very tall and skinny and
they're constantly launching insults at
him
your characters that are brilliant and
devastating at the same time yeah
because he and I share a similar
physique I often take them to heart when
yeah yes do any of them come to mind any
of the really good ones he's very very
tall and I'm just curious what are some
of the good for what Ben Ben recently
said you don't want to go to prison
because prisoners will be stacking
themselves on top of each other to talk
about um I like they took hours to pull
you out of your mother yes he also said
that he was he called him Frankenstein
monster Frankenstein was made entirely
of dead dick
you